hey guys it's justine from 2021 i
promise you haven't accidentally clicked
onto an old i just seen video from the
past i know this white wall may have
thrown you off but i'm actually in the
process of moving to a new studio so
this is currently my temporary setup but
it's not what we're going to talk about
today because today we're talking about
the apple event that just happened and
oh my goodness
so much was packed into this event it
wasn't even that long of an event it was
barely even a month ago that apple
released the new iphone and then the new
apple watch but guess what this year is
not over yet apple has announced a bunch
of new things today the biggest news
from this event is that apple has now
released two new versions of their m1
chip and two new macbook pros there were
also a bunch of other announcements in
the world of music a new apple music
plan new colorful homepod minis and
something that i'm extremely excited
about a brand new upgrade for the
airpods not the airpods pro the third
generation of the airpods also a side
note before we really get into things
during this event tim cook was actually
he was in the field it looked like he
was like all alone just hanging out in
front of apple campus but like john and
johnny and craig they're all inside
hanging out inside apple campus all
comfy cozy and then to him he looks like
he's out there on a safari like in the
weeds i didn't even think anything of it
until i saw a couple people on twitter
mention it i was like you're right why
is he standing in some some tall high
grass so honestly apple like if you need
someone to come by and mow your grass
like i would be happy to do it because i
feel like i'm gonna need to take out a
few extra jobs to pay for this fourth
quarter of our new apple here that you
all just dropped on us from the heavenly
apple gods above
so these new third generation of airpods
is actually a huge upgrade i am such a
huge fan of the original design of the
airpods so when they announced this i
honestly was like freaking out because i
still use my original airpods there's a
new design it's a new ergonomic shape
shorter stems and they brought over the
force sensor from the pros to these air
pods for more control now both the case
and the air pods themselves have a new
ipx4 sweat and water resistance and
there's a new skin detect sensor so
they'll be able to sense if they're
actually in your ear as opposed to a
pocket or just sitting on a desk it's
also kind of interesting to note that
the airpods pro only have the ipx4
rating on the earbuds themselves not the
actual case so these brand new
generation 3 airpods the case and the
buzz themselves are both ipx4 rated now
as far as sound quality goes they have
this all new low distortion drivers that
produce better bass and cleaner highs
but they also now support adaptive eq
which they first introduced with the
airpods pro so depending upon your
environment your ear shape it will
change the way that the audio sounds to
make it as accurate as possible now the
case itself actually got a big upgrade
which now supports magsafe and wireless
charging it will give you four full
charges in addition to the six hours of
listening time on the new airpods now
this is a pretty big upgrade but they
are keeping the price the same at 179
and the second gen airpods are getting a
discount and will now cost 129. now the
airpods pro are also now getting a
magsafe case but the price is still
staying the same at 249. there were some
more music related announcements
including a new subscription plan for
apple music and some new colorful
homepod minis i was a little bit
confused about the voice plan when they
first announced it it's half the price
of the normal plan but it basically
limits you to only using voice commands
with siri to play music now you won't be
able to browse the apple music library
on any of your devices you won't be able
to save the songs or make playlists and
it does not include support for spatial
audio or lossless audio like the other
plans and it won't let you play audio on
third-party speaker systems like sonos
that does seem like it's a lot of
restrictions but if you think about it
this is only 4.99 a month and this might
be one of the least expensive streaming
plans out of all of the streaming
products out there this could be the
perfect plan for a lot of people who
just want a casual listening experience
plus you're still gonna get the ad free
access to apple music radio 24 7 as well
as hundreds of brand new mood and
activity playlist and i actually didn't
even realize this but i don't think that
i ever even use the apple music app at
all i don't ever open it i hardly ever
use it most of the time i'm always
asking siri to just play music to play
90s rock to play a specific album to
play a specific song a specific artist
or a lot of times i was like hey play a
chill out playlist so for scenarios like
that
the voice plan is actually pretty
perfect that also would be pretty
perfect to use with one of these new
homepod minis now they didn't make any
actual hardware updates but they do now
come in five colors in addition to the
white and space gray you can now get a
little home pod in orange yellow and
blue i would have loved to have seen
them do the entire imac lineup color on
these because that purple would have
been in my shopping cart faster than you
can say m1 max
macbook pro 5 five times fast m1 max pro
oh my god wait okay i need to think
about this m1 m1 max pro
macbook
m1
it's a macbook pro m1
max pro
shoot speaking of which let's move on to
the new m1 chips now we knew these new
chips were coming eventually but what we
didn't know was what the final name
would be now apple started this
transition into using their own chips
with the m1 last year in the macbook air
the 13-inch macbook pro and of course
the mac mini now this m1
13-inch macbook pro is basically what i
have run my entire business off of this
past year i have edited so many
processor intensive videos on this i've
done massive 4k projects i've even
edited a bunch of 8k videos on this
thing so to put that in perspective this
here
is
the worst m1 macbook that they'll ever
make and it is the best macbook that
they've ever made if that makes any
sense to you but what i'm trying to say
is the thing is so incredible and that
was just making me get super hyped up
for what the future of apple silicon was
gonna look like the m1 was already
pretty mind-blowing with what it could
do but now they've officially announced
these two brand new m1 chips the m1 pro
and the m1 max there is so much to talk
about with these new processors but the
main takeaway is that this is a massive
upgrade from the original m1 with huge
boosts in performance but also massive
improvements in power consumption and
when i think about the macbook that i
ordered i ordered the spec out macbook
pro
m1 max it's going to take me a while to
figure out these naming conventions and
not mess it up every single time m1
max macbook pro completely specked out
with an 8 terabyte hard drive i also
inspected out with a 32 gigs of ram this
thing is going to be so powerful that
honestly i think it might even replace
my mac pro i can basically just dock it
to my pro displays you can actually link
up three pro display xdrs plus it has an
hdmi out so you'll even be able to hook
up a 4k television to it so that's a lot
of action happening i do only have two
pro display xdrs so i think that's
that's probably good enough i think i'll
be good right there on the m1 pro you
can only hook up two pro display xcrs
but again you do have that hdmi out
which would be really great if you want
to just sync that to a television or any
type of monitor basically these chips
are going to be insanely fast and the
best part is they are powering two brand
new fully redesigned macbook pros and
these look so awesome i can't wait to
check them out they have bigger screens
smaller bezels but there is also
a notch i know what some of you guys are
thinking because i was reading your
tweets and you guys were crying about
the notch on the macbook and honestly
this macbook could have a freaking hole
cut out of the center of the display and
i feel like i would probably be more
productive than five of my macbooks
previous to the m1 i would still be more
productive with half the screen cut off
so the overall design of this case is
all new there's an all new aluminum
enclosure with new thermal design it's
16.8 millimeters thin and 4.7 pounds for
the 16 inch and 3.5 pounds and 15.5
millimeters thin for the 14. this new
design shape is actually kind of
reminding me of those first macbooks
that came out in 2006 and that was
actually one of the first macbooks that
i ever purchased for myself and that's
actually what i made a bunch of my first
youtube videos on i used the isight
camera that was built into that macbook
to make a lot of the first videos that i
ever posted to youtube and speaking of a
camera they also made the upgrade to the
facetime camera it's now a 1080p camera
and it has a faster aperture for 2x
better low light performance the studio
quality mics also got an upgrade with 60
lower noise floor that will make
recordings sound much better the
speakers also got an upgrade with larger
woofers and tweeters for deeper bass and
cleaner highs and of course spatial
audio is now supported on both models as
well and i'm sure some of you guys might
be excited about this but they did
replace the touch bar with the standard
function row keys i personally really
liked the touch bar i'm not sure
if you're a fan but if you are let's do
a little hands up in the comments they
didn't really make much mention of the
keyboard so i'm curious if it's going to
be sort of the same style as the m1
because i know there's always so much
drama about the macbook keyboards also
hallelujah apple has brought back the
ports can we get a round of applause
here in the studio anybody no just i'm
the only one here cool great well let's
add a sound effect
the new macbook pros now have three
thunderbolt 4 ports a full-size hdmi
port and
they brought back the sd card slot now
this is great but um i stopped using sd
cards almost like two years ago at this
point i now use all cf express cards so
this is really just more of kind of like
like a slap in the face like cool just
scene we remember when you used to use
sd cards
and now you don't i do actually
sometimes still use sd cards so i'm just
kind of being a little bit dramatic i'm
actually pretty excited about this
because there are times that i will just
throw a few files on an sd card and i'll
be able to just transfer those and i
won't have to look for a freaking dongle
i won't even need a dongle for an hdmi i
have oh boy i'm just thinking about the
possibilities dude i'm hyped i'm so
freaking excited now in addition to the
return of those porch that we just
discussed apple has also brought back
freaking mag safe charging okay but this
was where i was a little bit concerned
because the second that i saw the
magsafe in the presentation i was like
oh wait a minute is this mean magsafe is
coming back but wait will i still be
able to charge with usbc because there
were times in the past where i had lost
or forgot my magsafe charger when i was
traveling and then i'd have to go to the
apple store to buy it because it was
like this proprietary mag safe connector
so you still can charge it with usb-c so
love that the displays also got a huge
upgrade it is a liquid retina xdr
display with a billion color support for
pro motion up to 120 hertz display and
peak brightness of 1600
nits so before this event i did see a
bunch of rumors about the notch and i
wasn't actually sure if they were gonna
go that route but they did so the notch
is placed right in the middle of the
menu bar which honestly is unused space
most of the time anyway so i think
everyone complaining about it just feels
like they should complain about
something because that's just what we
like to do we need something fun to
complain about so
there you go have fun you're gonna be
fine let's just take a deep breath let's
get out our apple credit card and let's
not think about it let's just go
shopping so all in all the event was
pretty exciting i know so many of you
guys have also been waiting for this
update i have had people message me like
my close friends family members who have
been messaging me over the past year
like i have some sort of inside
information about
apple and i'm like dude i don't i know
nothing i absolutely i don't i know just
as much as you do so now i can go out to
all of the people who were asking me
over the past year when apple was going
to announce their new macbooks and i can
say um you can go shopping now i would
love to hear from you guys though what
would you like me to test out with all
of these things that have been announced
don't forget to subscribe hit the bell
so you'll be notified when i post new
videos and i'll see you guys in the next
one bye
[Music]